So, das Teams den Scheiß immer umstellt, so ein Crap, so Leute ganz kurzer Stream, nein
ich habe kein Corona, wobei man weiß ja nie.
Wollte ich jetzt auf Reddit aufmachen, voll vergessen, null, keine Ahnung, Reddit Startseite
kann man ja nicht aufmachen, man muss wenn er auf Monkathos frischen, ja.
Also Leute, ich kann euch nicht sagen wie lang das geht, nicht lang, ich habe nur gedacht
ich mache mal ganz kurz an, mir geht es im Ding besser als die letzten Tage, deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht ich mache mal kurz an, aber nicht lang, wie gesagt, also, oh Mist,
wo ist meine Fernbedienung für die Klimaanlage, äh, KS, hier ist huge warm drin, Alter, d.h.
ich husten muss liegt übrigens nicht daran, dass ich erkältet bin oder so, sondern, weil
ich ungefähr, lass mal quickmuffs machen, ungefähr 3,5 oder 4 Kilo Wasser rausgekackt
habe in den letzten Tagen, ich weiß, MonkaS, ja, und da ist alles ein bisschen, äh, ähm,
weniger belastbar, ja, oh shit, das trifft, ich muss mal kurz, äh, warte mal, ich muss
mal ganz kurz hier meinen, ähm, für die Klimaanlage holen, es ist viel zu warm hier
drin, wie gesagt, ich weiß sowie nicht genau, wie lang es geht.
Das habe ich auch noch gemutet, ähm, ja, also, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wo es
herkommt, ich bin mir zu 99% sicher, was das, was das Ganze ausgelöst hat, ich habe, ähm,
ich habe das Ganze so ungefähr seit, ungefähr seit so Freitagmittag und das Einzige, was
ich gegessen habe, bis das, also, ganzen Freitag, also guckt mal, mal vor dem Toastbrot außen
vor, war, ich habe mir mittags einen Döner-Teller bestellt und wenn man mal so guckt, wenn man
so Lebensmittel vergiftet und guckt, sind, ich kann gar nicht, Symptome, ich kann gar
nicht mehr richtig schreiben, ja, Übelkeit erbrechen, Durchfall, Bauchkrämpfe, der Nett-Doktor,
der weiß Bescheid, so, habe ich, habe ich, habe ich bis zu 39 Grad, habe ich, äh, kotzen
musste ich zum Glück nicht, das ist für mich das Schlimmste an sowas, wenn es einem eh
schon scheiße geht und dann auch noch kotzen, das ist voll für den Arsch, äh, Kopfschmerzen
hatte ich wie Sau, habe ich immer noch ein bisschen, ich weiß, es könnte auch alles
ein Gehirntumor sein, man weiß das natürlich nicht, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, das nach
dem Döner-Teller, ein, irgendwie so eine Lebensmittel-Vergiftung, Infektion, was auch immer, ist, ist doch relativ
wahrscheinlich, ja, es, vielleicht ist auch Corona, ja, aber gerade dadurch, dass es
jetzt die letzten drei Tage extrem war und seit heute zumindest der Durchfall ein bisschen
besser ist, wobei immer noch, egal, ihr wollt es wahrscheinlich gar nicht so sehr im Detail
wissen, wobei man weiß ja nie, äh, Roffel, ich werde da auch nichts mal bestellen.
Ich hab das bestellt, ich hab, ich, ich wollte gerade den Laden schon aufmachen, aber erstens,
äh, ich bin mir ja nicht wirklich sicher, ob die das waren und zweitens, ähm, bringt
jetzt, bringt jetzt auch nichts, so, zumindest, äh, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, zumindest,
ähm, ich bestell gar nichts mehr, aber es passt auch vom Essen her, ich mein, es war
Freitag, was, glaube ich, jetzt nicht übertrieben warm, aber sommerlich, ja, Freitag, wann war,
was war Freitag, eui, ich kann nicht rechnen, Freitag, 31., 32, 31 Inch in Zentimeter,
Juli, Wetter, Hanau, guck mal mal, Akku-Wetter, ok, was war immer, was war da für ein Wetter,
ja, jetzt sehr, ja, Moment, was war Freitag noch mal, der 31., oh, guck mal, der war relativ
warm, ähm, so, und ich hab bestellt den Döner-Teller mit Pommes-Fritz, äh, bisschen Gemüse-Zeug
dabei halt, Brot und so einer komischen Joghurt-Sauce, so, hast du Fieber, ja, hab ich auch, bis
ich gesagt, bis zu 39 Grad, also ich, ich, ich kratz jetzt nicht ab da dran oder so,
also ich sag, ich sag, die letzten drei Tage ging mir echt scheiße, ich, deswegen hab ich
auch keinen Aufwachstream gemacht, das ist übel scheiße, ich kenne das gar nicht, ich
hab, ich, ich, also, wir hatten nicht immer kurz ein bisschen Durchfall, ja, aber sowas
kann ich mich, kann ich mich nicht dran erinnern, dass ich das die letzten, keine Ahnung, 15
Jahre mal hatte oder so, aber bei dieser, bei dieser, äh, Temperatur, vor allem auch
in so einem Laden, und so einer Joghurt-Sauce, ja, das kann schon, was hat mir vor zwei bis
drei Tagen deinen halben Kanal angeschaut, runtergeladen, ja, ich lösch den nicht, aber
mein Lad ruhig runter, ja, aber muss ich keine Gedanken machen, dass das bald weg ist, danke
für alles, ja, schön, dass du da bist, so, ja, ja, ich weiß, Twitter hat auch schon analysiert,
Twitter hat auch schon analysiert, wie gesagt, nachdem es jetzt wieder ein bisschen besser
ist, ich hab heute schon mal einen Kollege angeschrieben für morgen auf der Arbeit,
ob der eventuell, wir haben, wir haben wieder ein neues Release anstehen und Besprechung
dazu, ob er die alleine machen kann, ich glaub nicht, dass ich morgen schon wieder so fit
bin, dass ich da irgendwas machen kann, aber ich hab mir gedacht, eine halbe Stunde oder
Stunde mal hier Stream anmachen kann ich machen, vielleicht bist du auch schwanger, nimmt man
da nicht eher zu als ab, hab ich euch gesagt, dass ich jetzt wieder unter 100 Kilo wiege?
Also, ihr erinnert euch ja vielleicht noch an den Wagen Stream, an den Wagen Stream,
da hab ich gewogen 102,5 und hab die ganze Zeit gesagt, alter, ich muss wieder, ich muss
wieder unter 100 Kilo kommen und ich hab's jetzt geschafft, 4 Kilo, 4 Kilo Wasser verloren,
easy.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich gemässer hatte, ich glaub, bis zu 97, bis zu 97, 8 oder irgendwie
sowas oder 98, egal, auf jeden Fall, nee, 97, ich glaub, ja, 97, ich kann nicht rechnen,
scheiß auch, egal, zumindest wieder unter 100, zwar aus anderen Gründen und wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so beständig, aber, naja, gut, ich will euch jetzt nicht zu viel erzählen.
Das ist echt, das ist echt komisch, sag euch, wenn ihr jetzt, wenn ihr 3 Tage, ich bin das
einfach nicht gewöhnt, ich bin ja sonst nie, also so lange am Stück krank, ich hab zwar
mal ein bisschen Durchfall oder so oder irgendwelche anderen Sachen, aber so richtig hart hatte
ich es ewig nicht mehr, man merkt 4 Kilo Wasserverlust echt, du merkst das beim Sprechen, dass
die irgendwie nicht mehr funktioniert, ja, bei allen möglichen Sachen, auch beim Treppe
laufen, da fangt ihr auf einmal voll, die Beine zu zittern, denkst du hier, drehst
es gerade Gewicht runter oder so, Elektrolyt, ja, hab ich, hab ich, hab ich mir schon 3,
also nicht heute, über 3 Tage 3 Stück reingehauen, ja, hab ich, hab ich, und das einzige, warum
ich pennen konnte ist, ich hab mir immer vom Schlafengehen noch Paracetamol, so 0,815
Zeug, eine reingehauen für ein bisschen Fieber senken und weniger Kopfweh und dann ging es
zumindest, da konnte ich zumindest bis auf die erste Nacht halbwegs pennen, aber sonnig
angenehm war das trotzdem nicht, vor allem, weil das nichts dagegen hilft, dass einem
der Bauch wehtut, Bananen und Zwieback beste, ich mach immer Toastbrot, Bananen, Zwieback
nicht, Toastbrot, Bananen und manchmal Toastbrot, Bananen mit bisschen Honig drauf und dann
kann man auf die Bananen auch noch Salz drauf machen, hatte die letzte Woche echt die Krippe,
war richtig scheiße, oh ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen, hatte ich noch nie, ich überleg
gerade, was war das schwerste, was ich mal hatte, was, da geht es nicht, ob es gut schmeckt
oder nicht, Roffel 1436, ich überleg gerade, was war das schwerste, Moment, die Musik
ist viel zu laut, ETF, warum, jetzt können die sich wieder nicht entscheiden, wie laut
sie den Kram abmixen, also das schwerste, was ich mal hatte, war, wenn man danach geht,
ob man ins Krankenhaus musste oder nicht, war, wo ich ganz klein war, ja irgendwie, was heißt
ganz klein, irgendwie so 6, 7 oder so, ein Schleißenbruch, aber das ist nicht wirklich
wild, das wurde ja auch in einer Sitzung gemacht, wo ich im Krankenhaus bleiben musste, ansonsten
ich hab eigentlich, ich hab nix, ich bin an sich, auch wenn man das so als, ich sitze
den ganzen Tag im Keller vom Computer, nicht glauben mag, ich bin ziemlich gesund, ich
weiß, das hört sich jetzt gerade nicht so an, aber ich bin normalerweise echt ziemlich
gesund, ja, Bananasalz, genau, da haben wir mit 36 Grad, Ikea Labyrinth gefangen, oh,
das ist scheiße, das ist echt schlecht, so, wie gesagt, also am Husten müsst ihr euch
nicht stören, das hat mit Corona nichts zu tun, sondern einfach zu wenig, deswegen hab
ich jetzt auch was großes zu trinken stehen, das liegt einfach an zu wenig Wasser, nein,
zu viel verlorene Wasser, ja Leute, wisst ihr, was ich mache, wenn ich so im Bett liege
und mir ein bisschen danach ist, was anzugucken, wisst ihr, was ich mir dann angucke, nein,
nein, ehe, es ist kein Corona, ich sag das Husten hat nichts mit Corona zu tun, das liegt
daran, dass ich, muss ich mal, bisschen Dance Game Way zu sagen, die letzten drei Tage
vier Kilo Wasser rausgekackt hab, die Sachen, die immer flasht, sind meistens von Schaum,
ja, ja, teilweise, nö, alles mögliche eigentlich, Steckdosen leist ich von Schaum, der USB-Switch
ist auch nicht von Schaum, das Einzige ist eigentlich der Staubsauger, was ich von denen
hab, all you can eat, nä, das muss ich mir jetzt nicht unbedingt angucken, ehrlich gesagt,
also was ich heute gemacht, was ich heute mal probiert hab, ich hab wieder Toastbrot
gegessen und ich hab trockenen Reis mal probiert heute Mittag, das ist auch halbwegs drin geblieben,
Problem ist halt immer noch, dass ich jetzt wieder fast schon auch 38,6 hab und auch
langsam wieder übeles Kopfweh krieg, ich nehm aber erst ne Pille heut, bevor ich ins
Bett geh, übrigens, ich zeig euch mal, was ich mir immer angucke, wenn ich im Bett liege
und krank bin oder im Bett liege und irgendwelche Gründen länger im Bett liegen muss, also
ich muss, nein, es ist kein Pornhub, falls die ersten wieder kommen, ähm, aber sowas
ähnliches, zeig euch das mal, Homelab, guck ich mir auf Reddit immer an, Homelab und da
gibt es eine Kategorie, die sich Labporn nennt, sowas hier, Filter bei Labporn und da zeigen
Leute ihre Racks, das mag für die ein und alle, das ist deutlich verträglicher Porn,
wenn man krank ist und Bock hat auf nix als echter, ich finde das Ding sieht fast ein
bisschen aus, wie meine hässliche Konstruktion, die ich hier hab, ja, noch vor ein paar Jahren
hätte man gesagt, was ist das eigentlich für ne ultrafette Fett, ne, das ist gar keine
Festplatte, das ist das Netzteil, ich hab mich verguckt, ich dachte, das ist die fetteste
Netzteil, ja gut, jetzt hat er sein Gehäuse von Opa fotografiert, das ist jetzt nix so
Dolles dabei, ja, Eluminato, 6 Monate, Dankeschön, ja, das guck ich mir immer an, weil da findet
man viel Inspiration und was ich mir auch immer noch angucke ist, weil ich kann, auch wenn
ich krank bin, nicht den ganzen Tag im Bett liegen und mein Gehirn gar nicht verwenden,
ab und zu muss man dann noch ein bisschen sich über irgendwas Gedanken machen, ja, Self-Forced
guck ich auch immer gern und Home Lab guck ich mir auch immer an, das meiste kann man
skippen, das ist jetzt irgendwie nicht so spannend, ja, das ist auch nicht so spannend, vor allem
der Typ hat irgendwie, was ist denn das denn, pff, keine Ahnung, 60 HE, keine Ahnung, ohne
kaum was drin, volle Länge, das krieg ich bei mir überhaupt nicht rein, manche vielleicht
schon aber ich nicht, passt bei mir nicht rein, so und, aber manchmal sind doch ganz, ganz
gute Sachen dabei, zum Beispiel wenn man sowas hier sieht, ja, zum Beispiel wenn man
sowas sieht, da ist immer ganz interessant, man so, ok, was ist das eigentlich, sind das,
ist das irgendwelche Hardware, die einem was bringt, dann sieht man an, das ist irgendwie
ein olle Dell-Kiste oder so, ne, juckt jetzt nicht so, was ist dein Setup, ATM, ja mehr
oder weniger immer noch das da ohne die 4 HE-Kiste, im Prinzip immer noch das da, nur,
nur dass die 4 HE-Kiste noch da steht, aber nicht mehr gebraucht wird und die USB kaputt
ist, die USB hat, oder die Batterie wahrscheinlich, ja, aber ansonsten ist da eigentlich nicht,
hat schon nichts großartig getan, ja, anstatt die 4 HE-Kiste habe ich jetzt was deutlich
Stromsparendes, ja, das koll ich immer gern durch, weil ich finde, da sind sehr inspirierende
Sachen drinne, zum Beispiel so Dinger hier, da frage ich mich, ok, was hat der denn da
drinne und sehe ich da, aha, guck mal da, er hat da hinten irgendwie einen Raspberry
Pi oder sowas drinne liegen und irgendwie den fertigen Synology NAS oder sowas, Cyber
Power, USB, gucke ich immer noch ganz gerne, na ok, was ist denn das für eine USB, vielleicht
ist es doch gar keine USB, sondern einfach nur Stromleister, aber ich denke mal, das
ist eine USB, das wird sein Kabelmodem oder sowas sein, wolltest du nicht ein YouTube-Video
machen, doch, ich habe nix gemacht die letzten 3 Tage, außer geschissen, auf dem Stuhl ist
natürlich Müll, was hier übrigens auch, das ist das gute alte Ikea-Rack, oder, ne,
das ist nicht das Ikea-Rack, es gibt hier auch ganz gute Inspirationen für Leute, die
es wirklich billig bauen wollen, ja, zum Beispiel die Dell-Mini-Server sind ziemlich gut und
was man hier auch öfters sieht sind so Ikea-Racks, das stimmt, ey, ihr glaubt nicht, wie sehr
sich das gute, das Klo lohnt, ja, naja, es gibt Leute, die bauen sich so Ikea-Racks und
das ist wirklich jetzt eins der billigsten Sachen, wie man was machen kann, finde ich
eigentlich auch nicht verkehrt und das ist irgendwo im letzten Abstell, im letzten, weiß
ich, Stall, unterste Keller-Ecke, irgendwas, wahrscheinlich mit 98% Luftfeuchtigkeit und
das Ding verreckt ihm in einem Jahr oder so, keine Ahnung, wir hatten auf der Arbeit mal
einen Rack, das ist jetzt kein Witz, ich hab da ein Foto von gesehen, an irgendeinem Hotel
hatten wir den Rack, weil bei uns ist es so, dass manche Veranstaltungen machen und da
haben wir, manche Hotels haben Partnerschaft mit uns und da machen wir das, ist ja auch
egal und da hatte jemand in einem Hotel, das ist jetzt, ist kein Witz, da hab ich ein Foto
von gesehen, den Rack stehen auf der Erde mit nichts, also auf dem Sand im Endeffekt
im Keller, in dem Keller war noch nicht mal Betonboten drin, das war in irgendeinem Abstellding
stand auf der Erde ein Rack und es lief wohl jahrelang so und ich weiß nicht bis heute
nicht, wie das funktioniert hat, wieso schaut man sich das an, das ist so eine Art Schwanzvergleich,
entweder das oder Inspiration, ich guck mir das gerne an, ah Leute, ich tu da Bauch,
es kann sein, dass ich aufs Klo muss und gleich wieder off, aber gucken, vielleicht gehts
gleich wieder, übrigens ich hab eine Minute, bevor wir den Stream eingeschaltet haben,
hab ich gesehen, mir hat auf Twitter jemand geschrieben, der gute Reload Jack, wollte
irgendwas wissen, gucken wir uns das doch mal an, was er geschrieben hat, Geschichten
aus dem Paulanergarten, ja die Paulanergarten kippen immer nur oben was rein und bei mir
ist das umgedreht, ja bestimmt Unity Media, was Unity Media, was hat der denn, ja zumindest
fragt er mich, du bist doch auf dem Gebiet sehr bewandert, könnte das am Router liegen,
wenn nach ein paar Minuten Stream die Frames komplett droppen und OBS teilweise 0 Kilobits
rausgibt, obwohl laut Speedtest die Vollleitung ankommt, also, ja theoretisch schon, ich mein
es geht alles über den Router drüber, also könnte das schon am Router liegen, aber dass
der Router einfach mal so alle paar Minuten sagt, oh ich droppe jetzt mal random paar
Pakete, wenn sonst nichts passiert, ist doch relativ unwahrscheinlich, ja, also ich würd
sagen, wenn dein Provider Wodafone ist, das schreib ich ihm klar noch, wenn sein Provider
Wodafone ist, dann ist es ziemlich genau das, was ich auch habe, hatte, hatte, seit die
letzten Male ging es ja halbwegs, seitdem sich da der VIP Typ, der vermeintliche VIP
gemeldet hat, ist gut, ja, also das würd ich eindeutig auf den Provider schreiben, weil
ich hab zwar bei einem Provider mal gearbeitet, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass ich so ein
super krasse Fachmann bin, was das angeht, zumal man da jetzt eh nicht so wirklich viel
raus aus der Lage erkennen kann, aber das ist vor allem weil es so random ist, die meisten
Sachen würd ich in der Richtung schon eher auf den Provider schieben, oder eventuell
auf eine kacke Config vom Router des Providers, aber eher, ich tippe eher drauf, dass wenn's
Unity Media ist, dass entweder ihre komischen IPv4 Exit-Dinger überladen sind, oder dass
die internen Inquity Peering Probleme haben, das ist ja Wodafone ja mittlerweile bekannt
für, übrigens ich hab schon mehrfach erzählt, passt irgendwie grad zum Stream heute, wisst
ihr wie Unity Media, oder Wodafone, die Dual Stack Lite Exit Points nennt, als Dual Stack
Lite wird ja dann kompletter Traffic über DS Lite, über IPv6 getunnelt, und irgendwo
musst du ja dann IPv4 rauskommen, wisst ihr wie diese Exit Points heißen, also wir haben
eigentlich den besten Namen, den man ihnen geben konnte, die Dinger heißen After, man
schreibt es ein bisschen anders, man schreibt es After oder so, ich will jetzt nicht danach
suchen ja, ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht wofür das steht, aber wer danach googelt
wird es als erstes finden, ich find den Namen After schon echt gut dabei, was Atres Family
Transition, ernsthaft, denen ist auch keine blödere Abkürzung mehr eingefallen oder
keine blödere Bezeichnung in noch blöderen Abkürzungen, das ist ein bisschen wie wir
auf der Arbeit mal ein Projekt Coq hatten, und es ist keiner, bis die Leute auf einmal
alle random gelacht haben, drüber Gedanken gemacht hat, dass Projekt Coq als Abkürzung
wahrscheinlich nicht so das beste war, vor allem wenn man es dann auch noch Projekt Coq
ausspricht, hätte man das Projekt, keine Ahnung, Coq, das kann man nicht anders aussprechen,
kann so befällig sein, es war einfach dumm das ganze Projekt Coq zu nennen, so ich schreibe
nach dem Streamer, das war echt bescheuert, ich schreibe ihm danach was, wie gesagt großartig
qualifiziert was zu sagen kann ich da eh nicht, ich denke nicht, dass es an seinem Router
liegt, hätten sie es lieber Coq nennen sollen, als Projekt Coq, das war so fail, vor allem
war halt auch noch die Projektleiterin eine Frau, die ist in jedem Meeting, das war auch
eine, die war immer so übelst, aber es sind ja viele Projektleiter, und sei es auch nur
fake, auch so übertrieben, selbstsicher immer rumgelaufen, dann hat die sich dahingestellt,
hier ist das Projekt Coq, und alle sind immer so, nicht schon wieder, nicht schon, und irgendwann
ist sie dann gedämmert, warum die Leute alle blöd gegrinst haben dann, zumindest, das
ist jetzt schon 4-5 Jahre her oder so, zumindest ist damals noch keiner auf die Idee gekommen,
dass die Leute doof gelacht haben, hätte was Sexistisches an sich, das war einfach nur
dämlich, er muss nicht in allem was Sexistisches sein, aber irgendwann ist sie dann auch gedämmert,
dass Projekt Coq kein allzu guter Name für ein Projekt war, ja übrigens Salesforce hat
auch einen super Reddit, Subreddit, wo man viele interessante Sachen über Heimautomatisierungen
und vor allem über Raspberry Pi Projekte lesen kann, und wo ich auch immer noch gerne
reinguck, ist das Reddit von Home Assistant, wobei man sagen muss, da sind viele Noobs,
die andere Noobs erzählen wollen, was das beste ist, also ich lese auf dem Subreddit
von Home Assistant, so oft Dinger, so nach dem Motto, Noob kommt zum ersten Mal auf das
Subreddit und sagt, die Leute, ich will mir Data Hoarder, guck ich mir auch öfters an,
aber nur als Beispiel, was da teilweise falsch läuft, Noob kommt in das Subreddit und fragt
dann, Leute ich hab jetzt meinen ersten Raspberry Pi gekauft, hab Home Assistant installiert
und würde gerne anfangen mit irgendwas einfachem, sagen wir mal, zum Beispiel 2-3 Sensoren
um zu gucken, ob ich vergessen hab den Kühlschrank zuzumachen oder ob ich vergessen hab das Fenster
zuzumachen oder ob die Haustür auf ist, was ganz einfaches, ja, so und anstatt, dass ihm
dann irgendjemand sagt, ok, dann brauchst du eine passende Wireless Technologie und da
gibt es die und die Varianten und dann, ich würde dir das und das empfehlen, nein läuft
das meistens anders, Noob kommt auf das Subreddit, stellt diese Frage und dann kommt der erste
an und sagt, was, du betreibst deinen Home Assistant einfach so auf dem Raspberry Pi,
also ich hab meine Docker Fleet am Start mit, äh, nicht Fleet, ich hab meinen, auch nicht
Docker, warte, ich bin krank, ich hab meine Kubernetes, ich hab meine Kubernetes Container
Flotte hier am Start, Swarm war es bei Docker, Fleet gab's doch auch mal, oder?
Und, äh, ja, ich hab, das geht nicht, ich hab hier meine geile Kubernetes Flotte am Start
hier mit, äh, untereinander, load balancen, host und so was und der hat den Noob so verwirrt,
dass der denkt, für einen Home Assistant mit drei Sensoren dran, muss er erstmal Kubernetes
installieren.
Das ist typisch Reddit, deswegen ist Reddit auch als Hilfe oftmals Trash, außer auf,
äh, manchen Plattformen, das ist im Path of Exile Subreddit übrigens ähnlich, da gibt
es Leute oder es gibt ganz gute Bildgeiz und alles und die werden teilweise übelst, übelst
zerrissen auf Reddit, weil sie mehr, weil sie Items brauchen, die, äh, größer sind
als, äh, fünf Chaos Each oder so was, wo ich mir denke, was sind das für Kacknoobs,
fünf Chaos Each, das hast du nach dem Leveln, hast du den Scheiß am Start, aber das ist
halt, ist halt, aber ist immer so, ist immer so, dass in MMOs war es eh am besten, in MMOs
konnte man von den Noobs halt auch krass profitieren, ja, POE auch, aber POE bin ich selbst noch
nicht gut genug dafür, aber ich erkenne, ich erkenne schon, das ist der erste Schritt zu,
dass man im Spiel, der erste Schritt, dass man merkt, man wird langsam ganz gut in einem
Spiel ist, dass man, das ist so eine Pauschalregel, die kann man es bei allen Sachen merken oder
bei allen Sachen, wenn man feststellen möchte, ob man langsam brauchbar wird oder ganz gut
wird in einer Sache, ist es, auf das jeweilige Subreddit zu gehen und zu schauen, ob man
die, möchte gern, Noob-Trash-Posts von den sinnvollen Trash-Posts unterscheiden kann.
Also, wenn man in das jeweilige Subreddit geht und sich die Threads anguckt und sieht,
aha, Noob, der keine Ahnung hat, der Trash schreibt, oder aha, jemand, der Ahnung hat
und Trash schreibt, wenn man das kann, dann merkt man schon, ok, langsam kenne ich mich
mit dem Thema aus.
Danke, Sebaro.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich unplein muss, ich muss schon wieder den Klimaanlage
anmachen.
Ich dachte, am Freitag noch, Freitagmittag, da habe ich noch nicht richtig gecheckt, dass
ich krank werde, habe ich mir gedacht, meine Klimaanlage ist kaputt, weil ich hatte die
Klimaanlage an und teilweise schon runtergegangen auf 23 Grad und es wurde mir einfach nicht
kalt, bis ich dann irgendwann mal gedacht habe, Max, du klingst zwar bescheuert, aber
mess dir mal Fieber.
Da hatte ich dann 38 noch, was habe ich gesagt, ah, es war doch nicht ganz Fieber gewesen
am Freitag.
Ich habe gesagt, ah, ok, deswegen wird es dir nicht kalt.
Und Data Horder ist auch ein super Reddit, da kann man auch viel lernen, wobei die Leute
da auch teilweise sehr merkwürdige Konstruktionen haben, das ist ein Subreddit, wo man sich
ein bisschen Inspiration holen kann.
Generell ist...
Kommt mir irgendwie mit dem Kanal vor, ah, ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, generell
ist es auf Reddit so, Reddit zahlt man sich, ja, Sebaro, aber mir ist viel zu warm hier
drin und meine Klimaanlage ist Big Brain, die kann man sowohl auf Kühlen als auch auf
Luftfiltern durchzugschalten.
Ja, aber bei mir, wie gesagt, bei mir liegt es ja nicht, ich habe ja nicht Halswehenhusten,
weil ich Halswehenhusten habe, sondern weil ich so viel Wasser rausgeschissen habe die
letzten Tage.
So, und hier sind teilweise ein bisschen merkwürdige Leute am Start, zum Beispiel welche, die
irgendwie einen, ich sage jetzt mal was abgedrehtes, aber garantiert gibt es da welche, die das
haben, Leute, die einen 40 node starken Raspberry Pi CFFS Cluster betreiben, mit externen USB
Festplatten, mit, frag mich nicht, 800 Terabyte, ein Petabyte oder so, die haste hier, ja,
die haste hier.
Es ist viel Schwachsinn dabei, aber es ist auch viele hilfreiche Sachen dabei, eine Sache,
die ich an dem Subreddit ein bisschen doof finde, ist, die haben lange Zeit dafür die
Leute verrückt gemacht, so nach dem Motto, Leute, wenn ihr ZFS verwendet, dann müsst
ihr mindestens ECC RAM haben und mindestens, ich weiß gar nicht mehr was es war, 2 Gigabyte
RAM pro Terabyte Speicher und sowas, das kam dann dazu, dass die Leute, und es hat mich
damals auf jeden Fall mit Beeinfluss, muss ich sagen, das hat dann dazu geführt, dass
die Leute teilweise für simpelste Nass-Geschichten sich die fettesten FreeNAS-Dinger dahingestellt
haben, kompletter Schwachsinn, ja, Herz390, das war so die Hausregel, das steht glaube
ich sogar bei FreeNAS, allerdings, ein Gigabyte per Ram, was auch immer, es ist auch letztendlich
egal, es geht ja hier darum, wenn man das vielleicht im Enterprise, ja, du hast Recht,
du hast Recht, es ist ein Gigabyte RAM pro Terabyte, ich hab's gar nicht durchgedreht,
aber trotzdem, es ist ganz schön viel, wenn man das in einem Enterprise Umfeld machen
will, ja, und man vielleicht auch irgendwelche SSD Caches hat oder was auch immer, ja, ey,
da sag ich gar nichts dagegen und ja, ECC RAM schadet sicherlich auch nichts, aber für
jemand, der sich einen billigsten Nass dahinten daheim hinstellen will und sich überlegt,
er würde gerne ein paar Features von ZFS verwenden, ohne da jetzt die riesige fette
Kiste hinzubauen, kann er machen, das wird durch ZFS nicht schlechter sein, Nass, nur
weil er kein SCC Speicher hat und nur weil er kein irgendwie SSD Cache hat oder weil
er nicht mindestens 64G RAM hat oder was auch immer oder ECC RAM, das wäre sinnvoll, aber
ZFS ist dadurch dann auch nicht schlechter als normales Fallsystem, es kann halt seine
Stärken nicht komplett ausspielen, ok, aber es macht es nicht schlechter als normales
Fallsystem.
Also es ist teilweise wieder ein bisschen Blödsinn erzählt, ja, es gibt viele Subrats,
aber das sind so ein paar Sachen, die gucke ich mir echt gerne an und was man auch hier
immer wieder für nette Tricks erfährt ist, wenn es mal wieder externe Festplatten gibt,
die verkauft werden, die man, wie heißen die, wie heißt das nochmal, wenn man die Festplatte
aus einer externen Festplatte ausbaut und die Festplatte dann billiger ist, ein Sacken
garantiert nicht, genau, Sacken heißt das, ich glaube Schacken heißt das, ok, Englisch,
Schack, Schack, Schachs, enthülst, ok, es heißt Schachs, also wenn man die Platte enthülst,
das ist doch mal ein schönes deutsches Wort dafür, oder, wenn man Festplatten enthülst,
endlich mal eine Übersetzung, die ich richtig gut finde, weil das triffts, das triffts richtig
gut.
Ich hab mir heute auf dem Handy, morgen als ich im Bett noch klingel, hab ich mir mal
den Gameplay Trailer angeguckt von Ghost Warrior und, nicht Ghost Warrior, Shadow Warrior, was
ist denn, Ghost Warrior, gab es Ghost Warrior, ja Ghost Warrior ist dieses schreckliches Schneiberspiel,
Shadow Warrior 3 und ich konnte bei jedem Spruch, den der Held gemacht hat, die schlechte
deutsche Übersetzung hören, ich hab mir bei jedem Spruch, oh Gott, das werden sie
bestimmt schlecht, grausam übersetzt, irgendwas sagt er so wie irgendwie, Time to open a can
of whoop ass oder irgendwie sowas sagt er und ich kann mir schon richtig vorstellen,
ich kann mir schon richtig vorstellen, wie er auf deutsch sagt, es ist Zeit eine Dose
der Zerstörung zu öffnen, das kann ich mir so richtig vorstellen, das passt absolut
gar nicht und er hat auch so ne richtig schlechte deutschen Übersetzung, so ne richtig deutsche
Synchron Stimme, es wird Zeit eine Dose der Zerstörung zu öffnen, das kann ich mir richtig
gut vorstellen, das klingt auch schon genauso als könnte es 1 zu 1 im Game sein, aber ich
fand es ein bisschen viel, aber die haben alles in den Trailer gepackt, krank ja, seit
3 Tagen schon, ich hab es jetzt lang genug ausgebildet, ich sag dazu nur mal das hier,
also wenn man seine Festplatten, ich hab nix im Hals, auch wenn es sich so anhört, einfach
viel Wasser verloren, die besten Sachen waren immer noch, wenn sie in Gears of War gesagt
haben, in dein Gesicht zur Hölle, ja, zumindest was man hier immer ganz gut erfährt ist,
wie man die externen Festplatten schacken kann, also enthülsen, wie man die enthülsen
kann, weil es gibt manchmal den Fall der Fälle, dass Hersteller zu viele Platten haben, glaube
ich, oder was auch immer, und die verkaufen externe USB Festplatten billiger, als die
Festplatte kosten würde, die drinnen ist, wenn man sieht mal, warst du schon beim Arzt,
nimmst du mal am Wochenende, Notarzt rufe ich dafür nicht und in irgendein Notarzt-Dings
gehe ich nicht, ich hab den großen Vorteil, ich kann mich bis zu 2 Tagen auf der Arbeit
aus Urkrank melden, also wenn ich morgen noch scheißen muss, mach ich das auch, und ich
muss erst beim 3.Tag zum Arzt gehen, und ich hoffe, dass es bis Mittwoch, Donnerstag
wieder gut ist, irgendeiner muss auch gucken, ob die unser Zeug richtig getestet haben.
So, wie gesagt, auch sehr interessantes Subreddit, ja, das ist so das, was ich mir eigentlich
anguckt, wenn ich im Bett lege, ich kann jetzt schon nicht richtig vor dem Rechner sitzen,
ich hab mich jetzt mal in den Rechner gesetzt, mal wieder Stream angemacht, aber wenn ich
die deutschen Texte schon wieder lese, ich will es nicht sehen, die ganzen Rassismus-Diskussionen
auf Twitter, ich kann es mir nicht geben mehr in Deutschland, es ist so ätzend auf Twitter
geworden mittlerweile, man kann auch Hashtags auf Twitter mittlerweile, glaube ich, dann
richtig neu laden und ignorieren und sowas, wenn ein Chef sieht, dass du Streamst, also
wenn er sieht, dass ich streame, und ich mich so scheiße anhöre und teilweise husten muss,
erzählen habe, dass ich 4 Liter Wasser geschissen habe und 3 Tage im Bett gelegen habe, ich
glaube, dann hat er keine Probleme mit, wenn ich morgen kein Homeoffice mache, stelle
die Texte einfach wieder auf Uganda, auf Arduino habe ich die gestellt, auf Andorra, so Chat,
habe ich irgendwelche wichtigen Sachen übersehen, warum kann ich kein Ad-Zeichen machen, irgendwas
übersehen, naja, hast du eine gute, wie ich ein Skriptbild ausführe, wenn im fremden
GitHub Repo eine Release gepusht wird, ohne ständig die AP abzufangen, im fremden Repo,
ich würde ja sagen über GitHub Actions, aber das ist ja ein fremden Repo, kann man pollen
irgendwie mit GitHub Actions, geht das, weiß ich nicht, geht das, ne, anscheinend, anscheinend,
anscheinend nicht, gibt es irgendeine Webhook-Geschichte, keine Ahnung, ich musste ehrlich gesagt das
noch nie auf einem fremden GitHub Repo machen, da gibt es doch bestimmt irgendwie ein Notification,
da kann man sich doch garantiert, da kann man sich doch garantiert irgendwie Push notifizieren
lassen, GitHub Receive Notification Repo Push, ach ne, das ist mal ein eigenes, Upstream,
ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das geht, ja, Webhooks gehen eigentlich nur auf dein eigenes, oh,
du bist nicht der einzige, der das fragt, notifizieren, ja, ich hab das absichtlich
gesagt, weil mir kein Wort eingefallen ist, was noch dummer war, also ehrlich gesagt,
aus dem Stichreif keine Ahnung, wenn du irgendwo denn, irgendwo denn Build Service benutzt,
sowas wie Drone oder so, dann ist es kein Problem, der kann dir für dich Arpi Sachen
checken, ansonsten kannst du den Raspberry Pi und den Jenkins hinstellen, also ehrlich
gesagt, da müsste ich mir mal Gedanken darüber machen, ich hatte bisher wahrscheinlich in
der Situation, dass ich das machen musste, easykiller, dankeschön, hab ich gar nicht
gesehen eben, oh, ist es so groß oder sind die Platten so langsam, da musst du irgendwas
schönes für geben, oder bitte, es interessiert mich jetzt echt, wie man das macht, ja, Webhooks
sind ja nicht für andere Repos, sehr interessante Frage, das müsste man tatsächlich mal ausprobieren,
kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen, oh, ich bin jetzt, da muss ich gleich wieder auf, ich merke
schon, dass es irgendwie zu anstrengend ist, hier vor dem Rechner zu sitzen, ja, hier eins,
zwei Monate, dankeschön, excellent Subscription, huge, ja, ich streame dann fast Standbild mit
1080p, 48fps, das ist mal was, da können sich offizielle Gaming Reveal Event Livestreams
was abschauen, die sagen, wegen Corona können wir es nur in 720p mit 30fps machen, was,
es gibt einen neuen COD 2020, ok, das gucken wir uns gleich an, excellent, was gibt es,
zeig mal her, COD 2020, eigentlich habe ich da keine Hoffnung für Großade hier, aber
warum machen die aus 5 Sekunden immer so lange Videos, gut, habe ich früher auch gemacht,
gibt es ja auch den stehend normalen Trailer, auf Twitter, Moment, ne, da, jaja, das da,
verdammt, verdammt, oh, juck mich jetzt nicht, das ist jetzt gleich off, so, wo ist das?
Faction, ne, wenn das Stadio ein Name hat, Camperdach, sollte das nennen, bei Modern
Wars sowas, zum Teufel, wie viele, 30 Milliarden, also wenn man ihren Trailer schon suchen
muss, da haben die das nicht gut gemacht, ey Leute, mir tut der Kopf weh, ich geh jetzt
auf, echt, ich wollte noch mal kurz reingucken, schauen, was bei euch los ist, wir sehen uns,
machts gut, bis denn, see you.